What is this brief mortal life
if not the pursuit of legacy
I rickon stark i call this
valarium i boremund baratheon
promised to be faithful to king viserys until
he's named princess rhaenyra targaryen
men would sooner put the realm to the torch
and see a woman ascend the iron throne
we play an ugly game you have
the determination to win it
history does not remember blood
it remembers names
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
house of the dragon trailer big surprise they drop
some new footage there's a whole bunch to talk
about so if you're brand new to the channel i will
be doing videos for all the episodes it's gonna
start in august this year as per the trailer says
it'll be just like my videos that i did for the
original game of thrones series obviously this is
set a couple hundred years before earlier in the
timeline it's all about the dance of the dragons
this giant targaryen civil war this trailer jumps
around in the timeline quite a bit so obviously
this show is going to feature way more flashbacks
just from the start and i think that's in service
of doing five to seven seasons plus however many
seasons they intend on going because the actual
dance of the dragons was only about three years
long the actual war itself didn't last that long
so all these flashbacks with the younger versions
of the characters and some of them are a little
more obvious than others i will point out who
is who during the trailer are meant to show how
things just spin out of control in westeros
in the years leading up to the actual dance
of the dragons this trailer is meant to focus a
little bit more on ronira herself her family her
father king viserys who's king of westeros at the
time in her remarriage to damon targaryen because
they're obviously going to be some of the biggest
characters on the show the two biggest characters
obviously being the leader of the blacks and the
leader of the greens the two different factions
in the dance of the dragons which is princess
rhaenyra and the new queen queen allison the
older version of the character they were actually
very good friends when they were young and they
kind of want to show that like they started out
being really good friends but things got really
bad between them as you would expect when the
iron throne comes into play so even though the
original show was all about who will win the iron
throne this actually starts within the targaryen
family it's all about the succession keeping it
within the family everyone posts all their sister
wiping jokes they even have that moment during the
trailer where you see the older version of renera
remarrying to older damon targaryen intermingling
their blood because they're both dragon riders
they both have valyrian blood they're both
members of the house targaryen which is
why during the main show later in the timeline
obviously when daenerys was talking to jon snow
all about being a targaryen white wasn't a big
deal that they were related because he was brand
new to the targaryen family he thought it was
actually a pretty big deal and she's like well
i never even thought about it twice people always
do this in my family it was like a non-issue to
her that they were closely related technically
she was his aunts they weren't actually like
brother and sister so it wasn't quite as crazy as
jamie and cersei if you're making jokes about how
crazy that is i would say the only spicier person
in the history of a song of ice and fire would be
someone like craster for obvious reasons but at
the beginning of the trailer there's a voice-over
dialogue that says what is this brief mortal life
if not the pursuit of a legacy that's actually
an older version of corliss valerion the sea
snake who is the ruler of driftmark here right
next to dragonstone their big vassal house of
house targaryen they also have valyrian blood
that's why all the valerians have that white hair
but he's speaking to an older version of rhaenyra
and when he's talking about going for legacy
he's talking about the beginning of the dance
of the dragons this big fight that they're about
to have like you see later in the trailer an older
version of vernier is standing in dragonstone in
the map table room around the giant map table of
westeros as if they're planning this giant battle
out then you see damon targaryen and dragonstone
with misery and their entourage a little bit
earlier in the timeline completely different scene
they're bringing a dragon egg to otto hightower
the hand of the king in the kingsguard later
you see them pull swords on each other like both
camps pull swords on each other as if something's
about to go down what i think is going on here is
that he's actually bringing the dragon egg that
he technically stole and tried to give demisseria
who's his lover who got pregnant with his bastard
because he wanted his bastard to become a dragon
rider he has the targaryen blood so theoretically
any bastard that he desired would become a dragon
rider his older brother is king viserys so like
he's the younger brother of the king he's
called the rogue prince because he basically
did everything that you're not supposed to do he's
someone who's always plotting always going his own
way always thinking about how he can win the iron
throne but when he got his lover masseria pregnant
here and tried to give her a dragon egg king
viserys his older brother was like hell no bring
that dragon egg right back so the kingsguard the
hand of the king went to take the dragon egg back
they're just trying to show you some of the
enmity between some of the big factions in the
targaryen civil war the dance of the dragons otto
hightower was the father of allison who became the
new queen remarrying to king viserys this scene
of someone writing that giant dragon to the red
keep is princess rhaenyra writing her dragon syrax
then this whole next scene that you see inside the
iron throne room is a younger version of king
viserys naming a younger version of vernier his
heir apparent enforcing the other current lords
of westeros at the time to swear fealty to his
next heir like he's naming her the next queen of
westeros the reason why this was a big deal at
the time is because he didn't have any natural
born sons to pass the throne to and typically
in westeros what would usually happen is that the
throne would pass to the oldest living male heir
obviously that did not sit well with princess
rhaenyra who wound up starting the dance of the
dragons we see a couple brand new characters that
we didn't see in the previous trailer we see rick
and stark who's the current lord of house stark
at that time in history corliss valerian himself
who we saw on the previous trailers he's the lord
of driftmark the sea snake probably the greatest
living fleet commander at this time in history
obviously they're trying to show you some familiar
things like oh remember all these big positions
in westeros these big people during the original
game of thrones series like they're in the iron
throne room obviously the iron throne looks a
little bit different there are melted swords all
around it but borman baratheon is the predecessor
of robert baratheon after they just got done in
the trailer having the scene talking about legacy
the whole thing with king viserys is that he knew
that he didn't have a male heir but he loved his
daughter princess prania so he would always bring
her to all of his meetings he would teach her
how to be a great ruler so her whole life she was
kind of groomed for this position to be the leader
of westeros everything was pointing towards her
becoming this great ruler of westeros but and it's
very big but later in the timeline her father king
viserys winds up getting remarried to one of her
best friends who's been living at court for a long
time the younger alison and he winds up having a
son with her so the king finally does have a son
so most of the lords of westeros after this fact
later in the time are like well hey we have a son
to pass the throne now to it doesn't matter that
he wanted his older daughter princess rania who's
now a much older woman to become the next queen so
became this big battle with the heir apparent
who'd been named the heir and the actual son
that's why right after you see that ceremony where
they all are meant to swear filthy to the younger
version of her character she talks to rhaenys
about what happened and she's saying that she'll
basically never be queen like they'd rather see
the realm burn than name a woman heir to the iron
throne rhaenys was the oldest living daughter
of the previous king who was king before viserys
the line actually jumped to him because the realm
held this great council and said no no we're not
going to have a queen take the throne even though
she's the oldest living heir of that previous king
the lion's going to jump to another family line
who's just the oldest living male heir and that
wound up being viserys so that's why they call
rhaenys the queen who never was because she was
meant to be queen but never was so now we
get to the dance of the dragons later in
the timeline and it's like a here we go again
kind of situation it's the exact same situation
then you see a much younger version of allison
hightower wearing her trademark green gown coming
to what seems like young raniera's first wedding
to lord corliss valerian's son layner valerian
then it shows an older version of allison much
later in the timeline after she's become the new
queen remarrying to king viserys talking to her
father who still handed the king an older version
of otto hightower obviously played by the same
person he talks to her about having the stomach
for what's coming basically this big dance of
the dragons like are you going to win this game
the reason why they actually called the different
factions the blacks and the greens is because that
was the color of their gowns when they came
to this big great tourney that you saw in the
previous trailers then you see corliss valerian
bringing his family to the wedding of his oldest
son layner valerian to a younger version of
vernier like you see their wedding kind of
play out a little bit like she wears white which
is typically kind of weird for her but it's meant
to be like a wedding gown there's a scene of
younger daemon targaryen also at the wedding
kind of laughing at all plotting his own game not
really taking anything seriously you see this big
funeral procession at driftmark with a bunch of
lords of the realm a bunch of the valerians a
bunch of the targaryens mourning this person it's
probably the death of her first husband leonard
valerian the person that we literally just saw
her getting married to earlier in the timeline
the older version of ranira seems like she mourns
him a little bit then she turns around and throws
some weird shade there's a lot of tension between
her and the older version of alison who's already
become the new queen who's standing with kristin
cole who winds up becoming lord of the king's
guard under king viserys then you see another
younger version of daemon being hauled before the
king by the kingsguard not wearing his armor or
his weapons this is probably him getting yelled at
by his brother the king like i said he is the
rogue prince he was not well liked inside westeros
there's a brief scene of kristen cole being
pissed off and then like i said this scene is
the remarriage of older rhaenyra and older daemon
targaryen letting their blood intermingle because
that's the customs of their family they're both
valerian blood dragon riders this also happened
before the dance of the dragons like they got
remarried before the actual civil war started
but you have to remember the daemon targaryen
also kind of plotting his way to the iron throne
felt like this was the best way to do it like mary
the person who was the heir apparent this other
person present her claim then they started the
civil war so he was hoping that they would win and
that would make him king of westeros then there's
a big easter egg scene of older allison hightower
attacking older ronira with the cat's paws
valerian dagger the one that arya used to kill the
night king the same one that littlefinger used to
help start the war of the five kings in the first
place she was just one of the previous owners of
the actual dagger zoom in enhanced behind her here
this is graham mctavish as harold westerling at
this time in history he's the current lord of the
kingsguard until his death when he was exceeded by
kristin cole then there's a completely different
scene of daemon targaryen at dragonstone going
to the nursery where they kept all the dragons
at dragonstone seeing a giant dragon breathing
fire on him his dragon was called karaxis so this
might be him then that last voiceover dialogue
is corliss velaryon again same person talking
to an older version of vernier targaryen saying
history doesn't remember blood and that's just
more of his conversation with the older version of
her talking about the precipitation of the dance
of the dragons the actual civil war getting ready
to begin gonna be way more dragons during house
of the dragon just way more of them were alive
at this point in history if you remember how big
the dragons got during game of thrones season 8.
imagine most of the dragons are close to that if
not bigger but obviously this is just like a taste
of the footage we'll get another trailer as we get
a little bit closer i was actually surprised that
they dropped it today if you have any questions
about any of the characters or what's going on
with the footage just write them below in the
comments and i'll start doing more bonus videos
as we get more footage i've already done a couple
videos for the series and the other trailers so
i'll link those below in the description everyone
click here for my full doctor strange 2 review and
click here for my full moon knight episode 6 finale
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!